up next in the finals from the New York
Liberty Sabrina UNESCO
Sabrina will start in the far Corner her
Moneyball
far Wing you may begin on the DJ's Cube
had a big first round with 26. Wickham
at 28.
gosh it looks so easy it does well one
of the things Sabrina's talked about
shooting this year for the Liberty if
she's never had this many open shots
before her career obviously Brianna
Stewart creates that gravity and it's
created a lot of practice for shots like
that Shooters cashed in on the entire
Moneyball rack and the story ball
Sabrina UNESCO is putting up a Monster
final round
wow she cannot miss whoa Sabrina UNESCO
my goodness
UNESCO on
ear this is ridiculous
has this Arena buzzing finally misses
she's already up to 31.
in the corner
this is incredible Sabrina yonesku you
can
the greatest performance we have ever
seen in this contest and it is
close
[Applause]
Okay Sabrina literally we know that was
a historic performance because the
shooters in this gym were up on their
feet not only your fellow contestants
but all of the players on the bench the
All-Star Shooters like Kelsey Plum
Chelsea Gray Alicia Clark how impressive
was that for you as you're in it and
getting that Rhythm well I was just
focused on making one at a time I wasn't
sure how many I'd missed but I knew it
wasn't a lot so I'm happy to have won
this and I'm thankful for the crowd they
were cheering me on the entire time the
consistency of your shot it looked the
same it's smooth every time how do you
get that consistency I practice I
practice a lot of these live reps
um so I'm able to do it today
skills winner last year three-point
shooter this year how complete of a
player is Sabrina yanescu right now
hopefully pretty complete
um obviously got a lot of work to do I'm
still trying to get better every single
day but I'm really blessed to be in this
position the best performance we've ever
seen from a shooter in W history Sabrina
UNESCO thank you